le seule réponse c'est 2 confiner la
population malgré la pandémie mondiale
malgré le ségur de la santé il y en a
changé les problèmes sont toujours
exactement les mêmes au delà de nous on
a besoin d'un réel changement pour nos
patients
[Musique]
on observe dans nos jeux dans nos
services dans nos hôpitaux des soignants
qui continuent de quitter le navire ne
soignant qui continuent de partir en
masse les conditions sont de plus en
plus difficile malgré ségur de la santé
un an plus tard on refait exactement les
mêmes erreurs avec trop de patients et à
trop de ses trois enfants trop de
patients trop de monde et on n'arrive
pas à gérer
on a toujours des patients qui continue
nourrir sur des brancards parce qu'on
n'a pas assez de moyens
ça fait deux ans qu'on est en colère et
ça commence à être fatiguant
[Musique]